jean rémy girard bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
sur rt france alors pour commencer votre
réaction à ces révélations concernant
jean michel blanquer
j'allais dire que ça ajoute de l'huile
sur le feu mais qu'en fait le feu était
déjà très très ardent
le problème c'est pas qu'un ministre
puisse partir quelques jours en vacances
ça c'est des choses qu'on peut qu'on
peut parfaitement entendre mais c'est
que là on était quand même dans la
préparation de la rentrée scolaire la
plus compliquée depuis probablement le
tout premier confinement que les
informations n'arrivait pas au personnel
et ne sont parfois arrivé qu'après la
rentrée elle même et c'est vrai que
ajoutez à cela le fait que le ministre
n'était même pas sur place ça fait
beaucoup cela aurait changé les choses
si jean michel blanquer était
physiquement sur place sur le territoire
selon vous puisque selon le ministère il
a respecté les règles c'est à dire être
à moins de deux heures de paris en
europe est joignable
alors saurez probablement pas changer le
protocole en lui même on est d'accord
mais nous on pense que la présence
physique dans ce type de situation ç'a
un impact notamment au niveau des
discussions gouvernementales
c'est à dire pas tant le travail au sein
du ministère que le fait que valve mise
de l'éducation nationale l'inde c'est
l'un de ces jobs c'est de signaler à son
homologue de la santé au premier
ministre et c'est que mettre en place un
protocole du jour au lendemain dans
l'éducation nationale ce n'est pas
possible ça ne peut pas fonctionner
qu'il faut du temps que effectivement ce
n'est pas respectée les personnels de
l'éducation nationale et ça c'est
clairement on le sait en politique des
messages qui passe beaucoup mieux quand
on est l'un en face de l'autre que quand
on fait une vision à un moment dans
l'après-midi alors que l'on est très
loin il doit démissionner aujourd'hui
jean michel blanquer
alors je crois qu'il ya un problème jean
michel blanquer un très clairement à
l'éducation nationale
et qui ne date pas d'aujourd'hui et qui
datent même probablement d'avant le coc
vide et j'ai fait de demander aux
personnels ils sont absolument exaspérés
par leur ministre par sa communication
par voilà sa façon de s'exprimer de
surinvestir l'espace médiatique et de
très clairement sous investir l'espace
de dialogue avec les personnels après
jean-michel blanquer il n'est pas le
seul responsable de la politique
sanitaire on sait qu'on a des élections
présidentielles dans trois mois
obtenir la tête du ministre ça ne
changerait probablement en fait pas
grand chose à ce qui est en train de se
passer dans les écoles les collèges et
les lycées au quotidien ça soulagerait
probablement pas mal de monde d'avoir
peut-être une communication un peu moins
désagréable de la part d'un ministre de
l'éducation nationale souvent on va y
revenir justement sur la communication
mais avant un mot parce que le
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes clément osbourne s'est
exprimé sur cette affaire est pour lui
jean michel blanquer air n'a pas à
s'excuser est ce que vous attendez des
excuses aujourd'hui
alors nous on n'attend plus rien de jean
michel blanquer donc s'il n'a pas envie
de s'excuser il s'excuse pas nous ce que
l'on attend c'est du respect envers les
personnels de l'éducation nationale
c'est à dire qu'on arrête de nous
changer les protocoles du jour au
lendemain qu'on arrête de nous demander
des missions qui ne sont pas nos
missions et qu'on arrête accessoirement
de nous les demander gratuitement ça
fait deux ans que tout le monde
reconnaît l'investissement formidable
des personnels de l'éducation nationale
jean castex le disait encore jeudi
dernier quand il nous a reçus c'est très
bien de reconnaître notre investissement
par des mots à un moment il va peut-être
falloir le reconnaître aussi par des
actes y compris par des actes financiers
vous parlez de communication le rappelle
le protocole sanitaire donc annoncé
depuis bizarre il a été annoncé par voie
de presse ça veut dire que il ya un
souci dans la chaîne de communication
entre le ministre et le personnel de
l'éducation nationale à ça il ya
clairement un souci dans la chaîne de
communication et ça le snal que mon
syndicat ne cesse de le dire c'est pas
un souci qui est nouveau à titre
personnel je suis enseignant gens
saignants lycée
j'avais cours le lundi de la rentrée
j'ai reçu dans ma boîte professionnelle
les éléments informatifs du protocole le
lundi de la rentrée à 11 heures c'est à
dire qu'on est essentiel les appliquer
déjà depuis huit heures du matin
certains collègues nous ont signalé
qu'ils ne les ont même pas reçu du tout
donc oui on a un problème à la fois dans
la communication et deux sur la question
des délais on ne peut pas demander à une
institution de plus de 1 million de
personnels qui a une organisation très
complexe
dalé appliquer des modifications
drastiques dans le fonctionnement de la
gestion sanitaire du dimanche soir pour
le lundi matin on sait très bien que ça
va créer plus de problèmes que cela va
améliorer la situation alors masques
ffp2 pour les professeurs plusieurs
milliers de remplaçant mobiliser ou
encore l'installation de capteurs cd
annonce 1 kg ont été faite jeudi dernier
à l'issue du mouvement de grève des
enseignants un nouveau mouvement est
prévu jeudi prochain ces annonces faites
par jean michel blanquer air finalement
elles ne sont pas suffisantes alors les
annonces n'ont pas été faites par jean
michel blanc car elles ont été faites
par jean castex et nous on pense que
c'est ce n'est pas innocent on a quand
même l'impression que il ya une volonté
de la part du gouvernement et notamment
du premier ministre un de reprendre la
main sur le dossier pour essayer
d'apaiser la situation sur les annonces
on va juger sur pièce on a une réunion
justement sur le suivi de ces annonces
demain après midi de toute façon on sait
que elles ne sont pas suffisantes il ya
certes un point sur lequel elles sont
même inexistantes 1 vous parliez des
capteurs de co2 en fait nous on vit
depuis plusieurs mois maintenant ping
pong entre l'état et les collectivités
locales et chacun se renvoie la balle et
à l'arrivée nous on ne sait toujours pas
quelle est la qualité de l'air dans nos
salles de classe et ça ne va pas
s'améliorer l'association des maires de
france a encore communiqué comme quoi
existé mais que c'était à l'état de
financer et pas aux collectivités donc
vous voyez je crois qu'on n'est pas
sorti des problèmes politiques et
sanitaires dans la gestion de la crise à
l'éducation nationale merci beaucoup
jean rémy girard d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt franc je le rappelle
vous êtes président du snalc c'est le
syndicat des personnels de l'éducation
nationale